so today I have here with me Massimo
pigliucci I'm very happy to be able to
grill him in in part with some questions
that I came up with and also some other
people did as well about being a
ciceronian eclectic and I should
introduce Massimo at least a little bit
before just in case there's anybody who
doesn't already know his his work so
Massimo is somebody who has two phds and
not in closely related disciplines
either but one in Biology one in
philosophy he is a professor of
philosophy at CUNY that's the City
University of New York at The Graduate
Center right I think and I don't even
know how many books you've authored at
this point
there we go I've kind of lost track and
they're not all in philosophy right
there's there's a variety of different
topics and I I suppose we should say and
maybe I'll give you the
um
chance to you know tell the story a
little bit so you were not originally a
stoic and then you got into stoicism
identified as a stoic now in the view of
some people have left the big tent uh by
identifying as an Eclectic and even as a
skeptic of of sorts so is that is that
accurate to say that am I leaving some
things out so somewhat I I actually
started as a skeptic but a skeptic in uh
in a different sense although I think
related to the the sense that we're
talking about in terms of ancient
skepticism so look before I got into
philosophy I was a scientist and when I
my first position as a University
faculty was at the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville
and I was there as an evolutionary
biologist
now if you realize of course for people
who are not in the United States they
might not but if you realize that that's
the Buckle the bubble Bible Belt uh you
realize also that I immediately run into
uh plenty of people including some of my
own students who had a problem accepting
the very notion of evolution Darwinism
etc etc and so on and that to me was
shocking because coming from Italy where
I never met a creation is in my life
yeah being in a town where 90 of the
people actually uh consider themselves
one version or another of a creation
it's like wow that was that was puzzling
the step was close from there to getting
interested in pseudoscience in general I
consider creation is my type of
pseudoscience
and um and so I started you know giving
talks and writing stuff about
pseudoscience now that's skepticism in
the modern sense of scientific
skepticism more evidence-based
skepticism
and so for a long time I refer to myself
as a skeptic as well as a secular
humanist I suppose uh but but then what
happened is that I run into my
predictable I guess midlife crisis uh
and that made me sort of all of a sudden
in question you know what kind of
framework do I have in life where do I
get my answers from that to this sort of
stuff and I certainly wasn't going back
to my real Origins which were
Catholicism I grew up in realm and so I
couldn't see myself a Catholic until I
was a teenager but there was no way that
I was going to go back there uh you know
transubstantiation and and God is one in
three he's like no I'm sorry that that's
not that's out of the question
and yet I found to my surprise that when
it came to real life problems like what
happened in the particular year that I
that sort of triggered the crisis uh I
got an unexpected divorce
uh in my uh my father died
and uh I was offered a job and I and I
moved across across country now any good
psychologist will tell you that one of
those things is stressful enough yeah
yeah you get hit by all of them uh in a
span of like literally three months it's
like whoa hold on a second here I need
some kind of resources and I and I
looked into secular humanism which was
allegedly my philosophy of Life at the
time and I couldn't find anything and
it's actually is is a nice set of you
know General ideas about we should be
following reason in science and we're
all in favor of Human Rights yeah that's
fine but but when it comes to much more
mundane and you know day-to-day kind of
setbacks or even tragedies like that's
not helpful that's when I started
looking seriously and systematically
into possible philosophies of life and
that's how a little later I rediscovered
as it turns out stoicism because when I
was in um High School I actually I told
three years uh no five years of Latin
and I translated Seneca without
realizing that we were talking about you
know a particular stoic philosophy
um and then in high in college I read
Marcus through this meditation also
without realizing that the two were
actually connected uh and they were
talking about the same thing so it was
really a rediscovery
and and so that's how I I got to to
stoicism now as you uh as you said I
kind of consider myself a skeptical
stoic in fact that's the provisional
title of the new book that I'm working
on
yeah yeah just today I got the the
contract signed so that's uh that was
exciting now what does it mean to be a
skeptical story first of all
it there is actually a connection
between the two types of skepticism that
I'm talking about uh one of the things
being interested in stores is one of the
things you do is you read Cicero because
Caesar is one of our major sources on
stories even though he did not consider
himself a stoic but you can argue that
if it wasn't historic it was pretty damn
close exactly yeah because a lot of
these ethics especially definitely comes
from from the story because and he said
so I mean it's not it doesn't make any
any mystery about about it um he's on
duties he's entirely based on a now lost
book by panitius who was a middle stoic
among other things he's he favorably
cites you know crucipus and which which
he actually had read unfortunately for
us we don't have anything from Crucible
but he did have it yeah uh he was a
student of posidonius and other middle
uh middle stoic so he makes no no beef
about actually being influenced by uh by
the stoics but he's also critical of
certain aspects of stoicism in
particular he said some aspects of
historic metaphysics and one very very
good example was is in his book on
divination where he blasts the stoics
about you know what do you guys believe
this
crap that you know astrology and
divination and all that sort of stuff
he's like what what is what is wrong
with you and the interesting thing is
Cesar there goes systematically through
the reasons why it doesn't make any
sense to believe in divination astrology
Etc
and in so doing he produced what I think
is the first uh treaty in on
pseudoscience in in the western
tradition uh in fact what we use today
the criteria we use today to look at
pseudoscience I really laid out by by
Cicero in ondemination
interesting yeah I never thought of it
that way
um
but that does that does track yeah so so
the two types of skepticism are actually
related even though most modern
so-called scientific Skeptics don't
actually realize it because they
typically are interested in science not
in philosophy so they they don't I'm
trying to change that I'm talking to
those people as well yeah well you know
there was a question that uh we got
through social media that maybe we
should
um
look at first then
um so this is actually coming from
somebody in Mastodon and she said I'd
love to hear Massimo's thoughts on how
the ciceronian eclectic approach and
we're going to talk a little bit about
that a little bit later what what
exactly that means can help bridge The
Divide between science and philosophy
the the topic of Science and philosophy
and the Divide between it's been
discussed a lot but what is What is the
contribution that taking this as you're
calling it skeptical stoic but we can
also call it ciceronian eclectic point
of view how can that help bridge The
Divide better maybe than
yeah well so that's a good question
first of all because yeah there is such
a divide and and and I think it's highly
unfortunate and the Divide to be fair is
the result of misunderstandings and
incomprehension on both sides you know I
know for instance in my department you
mentioned the guided Center uh at CUNY
right so in my department there the joke
is that if you want to end a discussion
you know after after the weekly
colloquial we go we go out for cheese
and wine stuff like that now if you want
to end the discussion all you have to
say is but that's an empirical question
yeah and then that kind of stops
everything it's like oh well then we
have nothing to say about it and this is
an unfortunate attitude that at least a
good number of modern philosophers
especially those that consider
themselves part of the analytic
tradition yeah really displayed it's an
unfortunate thing it's like these these
react rejection of science like well if
it's scientific it's not my business
it's like what do you mean it's not your
business the science both philosophy and
Science and in the business of
understanding the world and what to do
about it so how could it be that
empirical evidence is irrelevant to what
to what you're saying
on the other side of that divide I run
into a number of really high profile
scientists and I I'm not going to name
names except for Neil deGrasse ties and
Richard Dawkins Lawrence Krauss um
Stephen Stephen Hawking Stephen Weinberg
uh most of them are physicists
interestingly although there are some
biologists in the in in the mix and
these are all people who basically said
what what has philosophy done for
science of late nothing therefore it's
useless like but hold on
since if we have met that as we should
that science and philosophy as much as
they may be related and Inter and
interconnected they're actually
different disciplines presumably they're
doing different things they're in the
business of doing different things so it
doesn't make a lot of sense for the
scientists to say Well when was the last
time that a philosopher solved the
scientific problem that's what science
is supposed to do right if I could
easily turn it around and say what was
the last time the Sciences solved a
philosophical problem
however that attitude on both sides I
find it really discouraging and and uh
and and irritating and in fact part of
the whole point the whole project that I
had in mind when I switched Fields was
hey
so I'm actually taking the the time to
you know not just playing it being a
philosopher but but going back and
getting a PhD you know doing the hard
work yeah publishing my thesis blah blah
blah all that sort of stuff so that
ideally what would happen is that my new
colleagues in philosophy will take me
seriously because I've done that job uh
but at the same time we'll say hey this
guy's a scientist so maybe scientists do
have something to tell us and then vice
versa uh my old colleagues in science
will say hey he's at one of us we know
him he's well known in our field so
maybe because since he's doing
philosophy that there is something
valuable here the result has been
exactly the opposite uh typically
I am too much of a scientist for the
philosophers and too much of a
Philosophers for the scientists that say
okay whatever
but back to the question that you got
uh yes I do think that a cesaronian
eclectic approach might be helpful there
why well because Caesar himself didn't
make any distinction between science and
philosophy of course most people at the
time didn't do it uh right right but but
I think Cicero even more explicitly uh
so both sister and the stoics as you
know uh
suggested that the way to understand how
to live a good life what they call
ethics is the result of two other things
logic to sound sound thinking and what
they call physics which we would today
call science or natural philosophy right
in other words you can't do one without
the other if you want to live a good
life you have to reason correctly about
things and you have to know your your
crap because if you don't know your crap
then you're gonna make mistakes and if
you don't reason correctly on that stuff
you're also going to be making mistakes
right yeah the Latins did have a word
for it and that is and that is sientia
that's where the word science of course
originally comes from but ciencia just
meant rather understanding of of
knowledge in many languages other than
English the term science actually does
mean any kind of knowledge
right exactly not just uh you know it
doesn't include only biology physics
chemistry Etc it also includes
philosophy it also includes history it
includes economics it includes
psychology anything then that improves
our understanding of the World falls
under the general umbrella of sientia
and in you know in German in German
there is a simulation exactly so it's
really the English that it's a problem
unfortunately of course the majority of
practicing philosophers and scientists
practice in English and so that's why we
have a problem
you know there's there's uh two
follow-up questions on that before we
get to the questions that I actually
lined up for you that I I'd like to ask
and one of them has to do with is you
know we talk about these big terms like
science versus philosophy right and when
we look at philosophy it's it's not as
if there's one single thing uh you ask
20 philosophers what philosophy consists
and you get 20 different definitions if
any definitions and they're usually
rather parochial amounting to the kind
of stuff that we do over here you know
rather than that stuff that they do over
there and with science okay you've got
disciplinary Fields right but it's not
as if there's anything with a capital S
science out there that brings in
consensus from even just the Natural
Sciences the physicists the chemists the
biologists and everything else that
might be connected to it and then once
we start bringing in you know the social
sciences it gets even Messier I think so
you know you mentioned that a lot of
these people who are
let's say say ah philosophy nothing to
it anymore they tend to be concentrated
in in physics and I was wondering if you
think that there's greater possibility
for an appreciation of what philosophy
might contribute good philosophy not I
mean there's a lot of bad philosophy out
there that has nothing to contribute
um maybe other certain fields are more
receptive to it so that's one question
and then you know the other one is it
strikes me that I see a lot of
philosophers who
sometimes it's straight out
pseudoscience that they wind up invoking
and historically this has sometimes been
the case in part because we realize you
know like you know William James being
interested in taking new thoughts
seriously and seeing if there's
something there and now we're like okay
that's an interesting diversion but yeah
forget that he was a great thinker but
you know he's got his little peccadillos
we'll say and
um it strikes me it's not just a matter
of pseudoscience but a lot of
philosophers will take
um big announcements by science
reporters about this study has shown XYZ
and then you read the the actual article
and you start clicking and seeing where
the studies are and you're like well no
the study didn't show anything remotely
like that right but philosophers and I'm
not saying all of them or that
philosophers are more subject to this
than literary critics or psychologists
or whoever else they seem prone to
taking in things that range from
pseudoscience to misconstrue levels of
legitimate science and then
extrapolating too much from that so
maybe the skeptic
attitude towards that is important to
have so those are two different I think
so so in in answer let's start with the
with the second question Yeah you
mentioned James but it's also fair to
mention that scientists themselves
sometimes go off of the rail I mean we
tend to forget that Newton spent more
time doing Alchemy and biblical
criticism than physics messing around
with Mercury and yeah without a lot of
safeguards correct
so so and and there are even modern
scientists to occasionally go off the
rails in in directions that um that that
really are not empirically based at all
so but I think you're right that that
tendency is clearly more evident in
philosophers and I think the reason for
that is because philosophy uh as a field
is far more diverse intellectually I
think than science especially if we're
talking about the Natural Sciences you
know if if we consider the Natural
Sciences people that get into the
Natural Sciences biologists chemists you
know physicists and so on they tend to
have by necessity these days a very
narrow uh focus and a very narrow
therefore understanding of things if you
want to you know produce something new
in biology or physics you really have to
specialize immediately now that is to
some extent true also in philosophy like
you know if you want to be a uh I don't
know if you want to become an account
expert for instance you're probably
going to be just kind for the rest of
your life and in fact probably a subset
of [__] for the rest of your life right
but in terms of General uh of sort of of
your
broad preparation before you get into
philosophy and also the way you keep up
with with the field in general it tends
to be broader in fact just just here's
just one uh telling clue that that is
the case we have philosophy departments
we don't have science departments right
we have biology physics chemistry
geology Etc there's no such thing as a
science department usually if there is a
science anything it's a division within
a campus that that you know the
university that includes a bunch of
different departments that's one thing
and if you go to you know as part of my
dual career I've gone throughout my life
to seminars you know weekly seminars or
colloquial in The Sciences in biology in
a grocery biology specifically and in
philosophy well when I go to the one in
the science it's it's only about
evolutionary biology and usually about a
very sub narrow subset of evolution
that's it yeah I never heard a talk
about chemistry of geology or anything
like that I go to the colloquia The
Graduate Center and I hear everything in
philosophy and yeah everything from you
know phenomenology
to the history of philosophy to
philosophy of your mind to metaphysics
it's like it's all over the place right
so I really do think that they're not
equivalent from that perspective and
that means on the one end that is one of
the things that attracted me to
philosophy the the notion that it is in
fact so Broad and it is in a sense I
think of you know you mentioned earlier
it's difficult to Define philosophy or
even science
but if we want to give a at least my
perspective on those two Fields is that
science is a evidence-based business
that tries to understand how the world
works very broadly yeah while philosophy
is interested in the connection the
connectivity between different fields
what a philosopher does in my mind is
and that's why it has a broader
perspective you know if you're a
philosopher of mind you're also going to
do metaphysics you're also going to do
uh you're going to be interested in a
number of other fields and you're trying
to connect them in in ways that may not
be obvious to cognitive scientists or to
psychologists or something like that so
I think that there is that difference
unfortunately however with broad
thinking it also you know the the
trade-off there is that more often than
not people might go for offer on a
tangent then it's probably not not
particularly defensible so I think that
your observation is correct and I think
that's the reason
in terms of your first question that is
are some sciences that are more
uh sort of friendly to philosophy that
has not been my experience I mean it's
true I think they're uniformly hostile
yeah uniformly uh either also or at the
very least in different indifferent yeah
yeah yeah now I think it can be an
argument can be made as we said before
that most of the hostility does come
from physics but particularly from
fundamental physics you know because
that there again physics physics is just
a broad field uh you know uh we're
talking mostly about fundamental physics
sometimes cosmology or as well but but
mostly it's fundamental physics that
tends to be hostile but then again if
you if you look at
journals in philosophy of science
for instance you do see a fairly good
number of philosoph papers that are
co-authored by philosophers and
scientists uh you know I know a lot of
colleagues in biology some in physics
some in mathematics uh they do coat or
they're interested in broader thing and
typically what that means is those are
people who are interested in sort of
broader more conceptual questions than
they get typically to address in the
laboratory okay yeah that makes a lot of
sense well let's let's move away from
that and get to some of the bigger
picture things so
um
one of the things that I wanted to ask
you about is this idea of ciceronian
eclecticism in the first place it's a
term that you use it's a term that I use
I think a lot of people are probably not
familiar with it they know some vague
things about Cicero but they don't
understand what what we mean when we use
that term so what does it actually mean
is it a kind of tradition or School in
its own right and why should we find
this guy Cicero an attractive model
given that you know it's more than 2 000
years since his as they say about
ancient philosophers Flora wheat you
know when he was flourishing you know
well why should we interested in Cicero
you mean other than he was one of the
most influential thinkers in both the
Renaissance and the alignment
um yeah well you know that's that's
another interesting side note because
you see him for example talking about
like the people not being interested in
this and being interested in this and
Cicero is the first person he brings up
you know nobody cares about Aristotle
these days you know this is like in the
in the late 18th century or shortly
before there's this Renaissance and
Aristotle studies and people are like
yeah Plato and Aristotle that's the real
stuff in ancient philosophy now that he
says but Cicero you know he is the
person that we we look to and then he
brings up a bunch of other authors that
we don't read at all right so precisely
his sister was influential in fact until
very recently all the way I mean his
political philosophy and ethics have
been influential with the founding
fathers of the American Republic for
instance so we're talking about up to
the 19th century
um so other than that why why sister
no there is no such a thing I I don't
think as a
cesaronian eclectic School although the
two of us could start one I mean why not
um
but what it is is first of all Cicero
considered himself a academic skeptic
right so academic because he was his
Allegiance was with Plato's Academy
but Plato's Academy during that period
uh have been gone gone through this sort
of skeptical turn which uh their members
saw as going back to a fundamental
aspect of Socratic philosophy right so
after all Socrates was famous for saying
what that he didn't know crap right so
that he claimed he made no claims to
knowledge and so that does go very well
with the general atlas of of a skeptic
after all the the word skeptic means
Inquirer and so being a skeptic means
that you do not subscribe to any kind of
dogmatic statement you inquire you you
search uh and and your cognizant that
the possibility that the search is never
going to end but you're learning
throughout throughout throughout the
process now in various places including
probably most importantly academica
Cicero explicitly says I am a member I
consider myself a member of the uh the
skeptic you know in the sense of the
academy and what do I find interesting
about this approach well it's liberating
because I don't have to subscribe to a
particular school and block so to speak
yeah I can take certain things from a
school let's say the stoics because I
think it works and then however reject
other things that I don't think that
work and I can pick from somebody else
in fact uh in several of his Works he
explicitly claims that from his
perspective there wasn't that much of a
difference between Plato news
maristotelism and stoicism we consider
those the three big and essentially
seamlessly merging into each other uh
philosophies that are really worth
considering he of course rejects
epicureanism as you know violent and the
kind of stuff that you know you really
don't want to get want to want to do he
thinks uh it declares the academics
sorry Skeptics dead so and which by that
time they were although there was a
Resurgence later right yeah with sexist
empiricals but by the time of Caesar
they were in fact gone as a you know
there was not much there left he
dismisses other schools that are today
we consider minor like the serenades for
instance the the true hedonists of the
ancient world war yeah you know the real
the real uh sex drugs and rock and roll
you know it's not not the epicureans
immigrants are mild by comparison with
the with the Syrian X
so so it gives in so doing it gives us
this interesting uh sort of Panorama of
all of the Hellenistic schools and he
basically says look there are three that
are really important and interrelated
and these three are the Uday money the
bigger you demonic ones the ones that
think that virtue is either the only
good or the chief good that's what what
Plato is maristatarianism and uh
stoicism having and of course cynicism
to be fair but the scenic's a little too
dirty for for Cicero so he really
doesn't the the places where he does
talk about them he's pushing them off
yeah and it is almost like a disgust
reaction isn't it right it has the same
reaction that Seneca has uh toward the
scene although one of seneca's close
friends was in fact the cynic uh
philosophy but Seneca also says at some
point um with a clear reference to the
to the cynics it says you know in order
to be virtuous my my focus doesn't have
to be dirty it's like my sandals can be
fine and I can still be virtuous like
yeah yeah so there's this yeah disgust
kind of rejection uh thing of of
cynicism
so now the the thing I think that we can
learn from that approach is to take
seriously the uh the the question for
which the Skeptics were most famous both
the peronian I guess and the academic
skeptic and that's the problem of the
Criterion the the pitana okay yeah right
so the question there was and this was a
big discussion between the stocks and
and the academic Skeptics especially it
went on for over a century so we have
some of the Skeptics that took up you
know Zeno and later Skeptics that took
up took on uh crucipus and the whole
discussion was very interesting one of
John John Salas books
think um
The Art of Living has an entire chapter
that's going to tracking the the debate
between Skeptics and stoics uh you know
back and forth but the bottom line was
uh this the stoics thought that true
knowledge is possible knowledge with a
capital K uh surely all only the sage
can have probably have it you know the
rest of us of course are fools but it is
humanly possible remember let's remember
that the sage is not a supernatural
being it's just a a completely rational
human being he's a human being who can
uh reason in the best way that human
being can possibly reason right yeah and
according to the stoics at least the
sage can get through knowledge why
because the sage is able to tell apart
Impressions that are truly catalyptic
yes truly cognitive from the ones that
are not well now what the hell is a
catalactic impression so a catalytic
impression is in is an impression is a
you know first judgment about things
that you simply cannot deny that there
is it's undeniable
for instance as you can see from behind
me uh I live in Brooklyn and it's sunny
out there right now if I went out there
and I told you oh it's sunny that's a
catalyptic impression you can have the
best arguments you want and trying to
convince me it's actually the middle of
the night no no it's not day uh it's
there's they're shooting a movie there
it's like and therefore it's very bright
because no there's no way yeah yeah
simply not gonna be able to convince me
that is an undeniable impression however
I'm not a sage therefore I could
actually be mistaken I I might think
that this is a catalyptic impression but
in fact it might turn out that it's not
a sage somehow the stocks never really
explain exactly how right well it's
probably in the Lost Books right that's
that's right probably in the last but in
the many Lost Books uh somehow the sage
can actually tell whether an impression
is truly catalytic because there is a
mark of truth that is something that he
can discern about that impression says
yep that's it that's that's the truth
and the stat and the skeptic's reaction
to that was baloney my friend that's not
gonna happen that is there is no such a
thing as a Criterion of Truth in
Impressions the only sources of
knowledge that we have about the world
are our senses and our reason and both
are known to be valuable well and what
other people report based on their
senses and reasons exactly because I was
thinking as you were talking about that
so let's say you are the sage and
there's no way you can be wrong about
the sunshine behind you sure my ego
would be very happy yes that doesn't
mean that I have a cataleptic impression
of what it is that you're reporting so
correct you know it maybe I get that
wrong somehow I misheard you saying that
it was sunny or yeah that's right so but
ultimately it's either our reason and
senses or somebody else's reason and
senses but basically these are the two
sources of of knowledge and the stocks
thought that well yes and if you're a
sage you can use those two sources of
knowledge correctly and discern the
truth and the Skeptics response was no
we we know that that um those things are
fallible and there is no reason to think
that anybody is ever going to be
infallible all the time I mean sometimes
they're going to work uh sometimes those
those sources of knowledge are reliable
but you never know
and um what you get out of that is
therefore what I think most valuable
about the skeptical attitude in a sense
the reason why an Eclectic skepticism is
not really a school
it's more of an attitude yeah and
specifically it's a epistemological
attitude
and the bottom line although there is a
lot more interesting detail but the
bottom line is uh you better go through
life always reminding yourself that you
could be wrong
yeah that brings up something I think
really important to stress which is that
within the you know Academy there was a
sort of extreme skepticism which said
well I can't know anything so you can't
know anything right and then there was
the more probabilistic type that that
Cicero himself is is espousing and
influenced by saying yeah okay we can't
have 100 certainty but I can be pretty
sure about this until something else
comes along to disconfirm it so I don't
have to like stop living or not make
commitments or say there's nothing too
stoicism because I can't prove every
single thing
um so Cicero's type of of academic
skepticism allows you to play off things
against each other and say I think this
is more plausible than than this over
here that's exactly right so the the
first Academy skeptic was our sister
Laos and our sister was basically a
piranist yeah that you know even sex is
empiricals later on says you know I
can't see any difference between these
two guys they're basically saying the
same thing
um and um and therefore he really did
say I know absolutely nothing I can't I
don't even know that I know or not no I
don't you know complete suspension of
judgment about any any of those things
that the person is called non-evident
matters right and certainly issues like
what is the the true good is definitely
a non-evident map yeah yeah but then the
academy uh the the skeptical Academy
comes through these the most interesting
phase which is that of carnitas
in fact that really picks up the debate
against crucipus uh and that that's
where things really get interesting and
Cicero uh is directly influenced by
explicitly because he acknowledges that
by Cornelius in fact Cicero so Cornelius
uses the word pittenon uh to refers to
persuasion to to say something when
something is persuasive then I'm gonna
give a provisional Ascent right so right
I'm not saying dogmatically that it is
what it is I'm just saying yeah it looks
looks pretty good looks better than not
therefore I'm gonna give a provisional
Ascent in fact uh carnid is actually uh
recognized four different levels of
provisional scent from things that are
barely more probable than not two things
that are really strongly researched and
exhaustively researched and so your
confidence uh in in that notion really
increases there there yeah there's a
really nice book on elinistic Philosophy
by
long and sadly where if you look at the
section on academic skepticism there is
this diagram very helpful diagram that
they show where there are these four
levels and they describe what these
levels levels are now Cicero takes that
and what does it do it translates the
word petanan with the Latin probabilis
from where probability comes from right
um now from there I think without too
much of a stretch uh and of course
remembering that the Ancients didn't
really have a modern conception of
probability that we're not talking
quantitative radical right right
mathematical quantity as we're but there
was a hint of quantitative uh aspect to
it because that's why Cornelius gives
you these four levels and it tells you
the second level is better than the
first the third is better than the
second and fourth is better best of all
and none of them is going to get you to
truth with a capital T but you're
getting closer and closer so there is
kind of a hint there of of you know
quantitative analysis now jump all the
way to David Hume
whom you mentioned uh recently who was
in fact a self-professed skeptic he
writes uh both about the stoics and the
Skeptics he's very favorable to the
stoics within certain limits but he's
even more favorable toward this the
Skeptics so in other words he was a
modern Cicero for all effective purposes
right now some of the uh works of what
the human says for instance in an
inquiry into human understanding has
been reasonably in my opinion
interpreted as an early version of
Bayesian uh thinking right Thomas bias
was actually a contemporary of of Hume
but human not read by his essay and uh
um and as you as you know bayesianism is
actually one of the prominent uh both
statistical and epistemological
approaches to these kind of problems
essentially Bayesian says as as Hume put
it a wise person proportions his beliefs
to the evidence right he were being
portions right so there's this notion
that your belief is not a zero one
situation it's a Continuum and that
continue you move up and down the scale
from zero to one
uh in proportion with the available
evidence I think that both carnitis and
sister would have been very happy with
that kind of uh way of way of putting it
the only addition that the well one
interesting addition that the Visions
have which I think also would have gone
well with the ancient skepticism is that
they caution you to stay away from the
two extremes of zero and one that is if
you absolutely reject the particular
notion so you give it a prior to use the
Beijing terminology of zero right or if
you completely accept it you give it a
prior of a hundred then you they can
show you mathematically on the business
probability theory that you're stuck
there then no amount of evidence will
ever move you from either zero or a
hundred percent basically you're now
believing something either on faith or
dogmatically right um right and and
since the word said that's why you want
to stay away from that sort of stuff you
don't because otherwise you become a
stoic epistemologically speaking uh you
you now claim that there are at least
some things that can be known with
certainty and that's where the skeptic
stops parts company with with the stoic
well let's take another question then
about well actually a couple questions
about stoicism in particular and and how
it figures into both your work and also
uh this sort of ciceroni and attitude so
one person uh
uh wrote it was quite interesting I
would like to know how you would have a
dialogue from an Eclectic perspective
with fundamentalists or people who are
treating philosophy almost like a strict
religion and then he says I also make
videos about stoicism and I've been
accused of not following religiously the
stoic Doctrine even though I haven't
declared myself a stoic so people are
weighing in you're getting stoicism
wrong what stay in your lane buddy that
sort of thing so I think that's an
interesting thing that uh you certainly
probably can can can relate to uh oh
yeah I've been accused of being an
atherodox stoic yeah multiple times but
I know that you have a lot to say about
the stoic yeah tradition right before
before that so
um here's something that I came up with
as well that's kind of similar so with a
philosophy like stoicism it's eclectic
in its Origins as you're going to tell
us in just a second with Xeno but then
you know once it becomes Consolidated
into a new philosophy aren't people
doing was better off like sticking with
the Orthodox or official standard view
rather than you know you look at so we
talked about Cicero being taught by
postedonius people in his his time who
are stoics were like that guy's not a
real stoic don't listen to you right
what's what's your take on on those
sorts of things right this is this is a
great question so yes first of all let's
the answer so The Eclectic argument but
well let's step back one more one more
step it obviously isn't going to be The
Eclectic answer to anything because
there's many ways to be eclectic right
but that said uh let's let's talk about
the position that the two of us are
taking at the moment which is a
ciceronian kind of eclecticism which
means something that is in fat very
favorable to stoicism and eudemonism in
general okay because otherwise you could
be eclectic about all sorts of things
you could be an Eclectic Buddhist for
all like for all I can tell right uh in
which case your answer will obviously be
very different
now I think that
The Eclectic answer to you know
shouldn't well be Orthodox it's actually
very easy first of all you just
mentioned in historical terms just point
out that stoicism itself like most other
philosophy philosophies started out as
eclectic uh Xeno spent more than a
decade as far as we can tell
studying with different people he began
you know started with with the cynics
you know uh um and and then moved to the
he actually was in in the platonic
Academy after Plato had died already uh
he started with the magarians and
learned some logic there so you know he
did all sorts of stuff we we actually
know from diogenous Liberties uh that he
had a number of different uh different
teachers and sure enough you can trace
individual historic ideas to all of
these influences right so the notion
that logic is important well that comes
from the magarians uh the even the four
cardinal virtues which a lot of modern
practitioners or stoics think it's stoic
it's actually found in Plato's Republic
and and probably is earlier than that
because Plato himself just throws them
in there assuming that people know what
he's talking about so presumably that
actually pre-platonic but but certainly
they're not stoic in origin you know a
lot of things that in fact if you start
looking at stoicism of course the notion
that that virtue is the only good well
that's cynic uh and and so on and so
forth in fact it's hard to find an idea
that is truly and exclusively stoic
perhaps my best candidate is the
so-called dichotomy of control that one
I you know Epictetus uh some things that
are coming so late though you know I
mean but that is coming like in in
Seneca and even in Cicero like you know
what is in our protestas
but that's about it right so now what is
uniquely stoic is the way these things
are put together okay and as you put and
as you said initially probably this was
a little bit of a mess Zeno put together
these things because they were just
interested interesting to him and he had
he came up with some kind of an Eclectic
synthesis but we're told by diogenous
luritus that the reason people often
said without reciprocs there will be no
store
is precisely because he cleaned up the
mess and he was a logician right and so
he said okay hold on a second certain
things don't don't actually make sense
it throw them out other things we need
to rephrase them to to see how they go
together etc etc after all we're talking
philosophy so you do want some kind of
internal coherence uh going on there
right you don't want contradictions
within your your philosophical system
now so that will be my first response to
you know should we all you know what is
that what's the matter what is the
matter with the eclectics well pretty
much everybody's an Eclectic if you go
far in time enough yeah now but then to
your to the to the following question
which is yeah okay but once the thing
settle down why don't we just
you know follow the doctrine and that
end of the story look for all an
effective purposes for many modern
practitioners or stories and that that
works because most people are not really
interested to be frank in the
intricacies or the history of the
philosophy they're interested in uh in
the same way in which I was interested
when I got into this thing to begin with
shoot my my father died and I got a
divorce and I'm stressed and what the
hell am I supposed to do about this
right yeah now when when you're
doing that sort of thing when you're
dealing with that sort of issues frankly
you're not interested in the in the in
the subtle things of philosophical
disquisitions between Xeno and
chrissypus and positive who cares right
um if it works it works and if it
doesn't work I'll move on to something
else
have the final you know yeah higher
reconsiration of the world right or not
right so long as it works I mean in fact
you know stoicism is a very very
practical philosophy so whatever works
right if it works it's fine if and if
not I'll do something else
but if you are curious because after a
while you know I got into stores and
after the classes was over I got into
something okay well I I now want to
learn something more about this stuff
you know how it works that's where the
question then will re-emerge the
question of you know how much heterodoxy
Orthodoxy
and there too I think that history is uh
a valuable lesson regardless after the
chat you know book Seven is on of the
lives of the eminent philosophers is on
the stoics
starts out with Zeno then it gives you
an overview of Fairly in-depth overview
actually of the stoic system and then it
goes through a bunch of others and it
tells you these are the atro toxic
stoics these are the ones that actually
disagreed with what I just told you yeah
yeah and there is a bunch of them
some of them eventually even left
stoicism because their disagreement was
large enough that they said yeah you
know what I don't even consider myself a
stoic anymore but some of them remain
remained most importantly penicious and
posidonius who unfortunately are not
covered by diogenesis layeratives I'm
not sure why because yeah
um me either but yeah I mean you know I
mean we don't even know much about
diogenes himself barely we know where
where when we live when he lived
somewhere in the city sometime in the
second century but he he mentions sextus
empiricals who was a second century
right in the second century so um so
that that raises the question well why
does he a mention sexes in particles and
doesn't actually say anything about him
but if you mention sexist why not
posidonius 10 issues or even Epictetus
for that matter or Seneca I mean those
people he must have known those people
so what the hell
um all right I don't know I don't know
the answer to that it's like it's just
one of those puzzles but if you go
through
that book seven on stoicism by diogenes
you will obviously get an appreciation
for the fact that there was never an
orthodox stoicism in the sense that
there were always disagreements within
the stoic community and you get to
Seneca and Seneca says explicitly uh you
know these people that preceded me are
not my masters they're just my teachers
if I find a new and better way I'm gonna
follow it yeah I particularly like I
think it's letter 120 where he says okay
the stoics they've got this idea that
the virtues are living things within our
soul and here's the arguments that they
give for it and here's why I think
they're completely wrong about this you
know this doesn't make any sense when we
get down to it so he's you know he's
still identifying as a stoic but willing
to call out right he doesn't name
anybody of course but right so in that
sense in the Seneca I guess and and
Cicero inspired sense I considered these
days myself a skeptical stoic meaning
that a core my philosophy of life is
still stoicism I if if you have to if
you ask me what philosophical tradition
East or West you most closely identify
with and you think you're following I
without hesitation I would say
stoicism yeah but I will put an asterisk
there and say and either either mention
Cicero in academica where he says yeah
but my skepticism allows me then to pick
and choose what I think it makes more
sense or not or I will mention Seneca
and uh and I said you know if if if it
turns out that certain things don't work
and of course the big one that doesn't
work as you know in my opinion I wrote
an entire book on this a Field Guide to
the happy life yeah
um the big one that doesn't work in my
opinion is uh that aspect of stoic
metaphysics that has to do with
Providence yeah yeah
uh so the stoics thought that the cosmos
itself was a living organism endowed
with the logos which is this
weird kind of who knows exactly what
they meant by it but at any rate some
sense of rationality and some sense of
you know thinking super rationality
somehow greater than our rationality
right exactly
now um
that was an important part of stoic not
only stock metaphysics but stoic ethics
because it makes perfect sense of
otherwise really puzzling
passages in let's say pictitos when
epitida says
um
kiss your wife and your child good night
because they might die doing the you
know by tomorrow morning and that way
you're not going to be disturbed if you
read that out of context you say what
kind of a psychopath is this guy yeah
what do you mean I I can't I shouldn't
be disturbed by my loved ones dying but
if you put it in the context of the
stoic metaphysics it makes perfect sense
yeah himself uses the famous metaphor of
the foot that has to go into the into
that right so he says if you're if you
have to step into the mud and you're a
foot and you just look at it from the
point of view of a foot you're gonna say
this is disgusting I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna stop in the mud what the hell but
if you remember that you're connected to
a body
and that you're you're done the entire
point of your existence is in fact to
help the body move around and sometimes
that means you have to step into the mud
then not only you're gonna do it you're
actually going to do it gladly
you're not going to be disturbed by it
this is beautiful I think it's
absolutely beautiful and I wish I could
believe it
but as a modern scientist and I know
that in within the store Community
there's controversy about this but as a
modern scientist I'm sorry I just don't
believe that the universe is a living
organism endowed with anything uh the
universe is a set of dynamical process
is described by the laws of what we call
the laws of nature end of story now what
does that mean it means that I cannot as
a modern stoic help myself to the
concept of Providence
so if my wife should die or my daughter
should die tonight no I am not gonna
embrace it tomorrow I'm not gonna be I
am going to be disturbed however I am
still a stoic in the sense that I also
rationally realize that a I have to be
prepared for my loved one's death and
from my own because that's what human
beings do they die we die right that is
the natural thing to do it's inevitable
and I also prepare myself to endure that
to accept it with as much Serenity as I
or Equanimity at the very least as I can
master so that doesn't mean that I'm not
going to be upset it just means that I
am prepared I know this kind of stuff
happens and I know I cannot do anything
about it so I still think that that is a
very much a stoic attitude but it's not
an ancient stoic attitude
you know it's interesting because there
is so with going back to Cicero there's
one other really big area where he
clearly disagrees with the stoics and
says the aristotelians has something
right that you guys are missing out on
um and then there's another thing that's
a little bit more loosey-goosey that you
know if you look at the tusculine
disputations I I kind of think the
stoics are wrong about the negative
always negative value of grief you know
and Cicero kind of skates around with
that but then you look at how he dealt
with the incredible grief that he felt
at the loss of his daughter he seems to
have been closer to her than to his his
son
um I I kind of think that he's differing
from them on on that topic as well but
so going back to the
the other thing you know Cicero like in
in the stoic paradoxes and and several
other places he he when he's talking to
Stokes he's like you guys have some
great philosophy you're terrible at
articulating it because you just like
put it out there and you don't you don't
use any of the forces of rhetoric and
he's he's not talking about rhetoric in
some sort of platonic oh rhetoric bad
philosophy good kind of sense it's uh
you know it's an understanding that
you're talking to an audience at every
point in time now you're somebody who
you know you've written a lot of books
you've engaged in a lot of public
philosophy you're incredibly aware and
attuned to the audiences that you you
have to reach out to I was kind of
wondering where you sit with uh Cicero
on that not to say that the
aristotelians figured everything out
about rhetoric they certainly thought it
was centrally important that's right uh
so there are those those are two of at
least three other reasons I like so much
maybe we'll get to the third one in a
minute it has to do with politics
um number one you mentioned his reaction
to the the the the the death of Tulia
he's his daughter which happened of
course at the same time when he was sent
into Exile uh again well it was it went
into a self uh imposed exam yeah because
his uh his political career allegedly
was over he did come back one more time
to criticize the hell out of Marc
Anthony and that's why he lost his life
because Marc Anthony had no sense of
humor
um but
so he was at a low point in his life not
for the first time because years before
he had also in fact been sent into Exile
after having triumphed as a console and
having you know defeated Catalan in in
the in a conspiracy Etc so his life was
a lot of ups and downs
and the way he responds to is the latest
down downside downturn is interesting he
acknowledges his grief at some point he
says to it one of the nice things about
Cicero is that we know a little bit of
what was happening behind the scenes
because we don't just have his book most
of his books we also have a lot of his
letters personal letters right right
yeah especially to his friend Atticus uh
who was this lifelong friend and with
whom clearly he opened up so we really
know quite a bit about what Cicero was
actually thinking and feeling at the
time and he's definitely distraught
you're not just this distress he says I
don't know that I can actually uh you
know emerge from this I know I don't
know that I can actually conquer the
grief
and then what does he do he writes the
first book ever of self-help
himself so philosophical self-help as we
will call it today was already a thing
you know the constellations was already
a genre but usually you would write it
for somebody else
yeah the last book unfortunately lost
book by Cicero on on Grief uh is the
first example we know of of
self-consolation uh of which there are
then later examples like uh Bush's uh
constellations of philosophy for
instance right right it's a great
example but that's later sister is the
first one that says hey I keep telling
to people that philosophy is helpful
maybe it's going to be helpful for me
right so he goes into his one of his
Villas he sits down it just starts
writing as a way as he says explicitly
as a way to uh help himself out of his
grief and it works it actually works uh
within a year it re-emerges from from
this thing and eventually as I said it
comes back also in politics so the
reason all of this uh brought up all of
this is because what that does is it
makes me
appreciate uh Cicero as a human being
as you know you recognize that yeah you
probably react in the same way yeah but
but
I suppose let's say a picture so it's
kind of you know it's unreachable I mean
it is you know levels are like whoa what
that these guys way above me there's no
way I'm gonna be able to live his life
but I can see myself reacting in a way
in which the sister reacts and yet at
the same time not throwing out
philosophy
on the contrary philosophy becomes his
tool to get out and get over these these
issues he actually acknowledges the
issue and works through the issue as
opposed to his friend Cato for instance
who was a stoic and he's accused of
being a bad stoic because he started you
know if he cried when his but when his
brother was was killed when died and
he's like so we don't expect Cicero not
to cry because of his daughter because
he doesn't profess to be a story so it's
okay right and so in that sense I think
that's one reason
I really like uh the second one is the
rhetoric stuff
yeah not only in criticizes the stoics
he actually criticizes uh somebody who
we very rarely otherwise criticizes
Socrates
he actually takes on Socrates and says
you know the problem with Socrates is
that he didn't use red he poo pooed
rhetoric you know he thought the
rhetoric is just for sophists and and
Caesar explains of course he being not
just a philosopher but a politician as
well as a public Advocate right yeah so
of course for him rhetoric is important
he's a politician and a lawyer
and he says look rhetoric is a tool and
rhetoric can be used virtuously which is
which is Aristotle Point Aristotle
pinpoint in the rhetoric is that uh you
know the logos the arguments are not
enough if you want to persuade somebody
you also have to add the Pathos and the
ethos you had to be you know speaking
emotionally to person Reach people
emotionally the Pathos and you also want
to establish yourself as a credible uh
Source that's the atos if you don't do
these other two things you can have all
the best arguments you want you're not
gonna win you're not gonna persuade
people and I think he's I think Caesar
is absolutely right and that's clear and
Aristotelian use of of rhetoric which he
did very effectively at some point there
is a in my last book the latest book The
Quest for character there is a chapter
that starts out with a quote by Cicero
where Cicero talks to Atticus to his
friend articles about Cato the younger
who was a colleague as I said you know
Senator and he says you know as far as
our friend Cato is concerned I love him
to death
but sometimes he votes and talks as if
he lived in Plato's Republic not in the
mud of Romulus
yeah
exactly so
your mind arguably his own
uh you know what he was trying to do is
his own quest for for saving the
Republic precisely because he was so
damn intransigent he didn't realize that
you know politics is about often often
as about compromise sister is often uh
criticized for being kind of sort of
changing his mind back and forth
throughout his career but in fact a very
good argument has been made by one of
his biographers
that Cicero had one and only one goal in
his entire political career and that was
to save the Republic and reconcile the
class struggle that that in fact had
characterized the Republic for more than
a century and eventually led to it to it
to its end right between the popularis
and and the optimatus you know I mean I
think one of the best Arguments for
Cicero
not just being a wishy-washy compromiser
is the fact that he was invited to join
the triumvirate and turned them down and
he turned them down knowing knowing what
consequences that would would lead to
because you know saying saying no to
powerful people like that
um who are offering you a seat at the
table you you know that you're going to
start having some some negative
consequences that you could have
prevented before correct so he was
conscious of the fact that you have to
compromise that you cannot always have
your way but that compromise has to be a
virtuous compromise and that's a good
way to put it with your with your goal
ultimate goal in mind the reason I think
he turned down the triumvirate the
membership in the triumvirate offered by
Pompey and and Julius Caesar is because
he understood that yes he would have
been much more effective at that point
he would have certainly gone in he's
programmed through but at the cost of in
fact de facto destroying the Republic
because now you have three people behind
the scenes Not Elected by anybody uh not
having any official uh charge at all who
are basically deciding what's going on
in realm and yeah that was one step too
many and I think he was right at Drawing
the Line at that level right uh yeah so
compromise yes but only up to a point
because if I if I have to give you the
whole house in terms of compromise then
then I'm done then it's the end of the
story so that leads back to another more
just meta philosophical question not
about uh politics or anything like that
about eclecticism so and this is
something that uh I was going to ask you
about and then then Rob Coulter
um brought up in in a slightly different
way so when an Eclectic is deciding what
to incorporate what to try to integrate
because it's not just like a smorgasbord
I like an olive here and a little bit of
prosciutto here or something like that
right it's like trying to put together a
coherent way of
understanding things
what bases can an Eclectic have for
determining this in a rational way not
just a gut instinct way not just of this
pragmatically works for me today kind of
way is is there something that we could
set out like a program for
figuring things out or a set of limits
where you're like no no you you can
believe all sorts of things but not that
crazy crap over there that's not going
to be successfully Incorporated yeah of
course Rob's question is an excellent
one I think that the answer is yes we
can
um
first of all I'm it's interesting that
your example was a culinary one
okay
um I mean even there you know if you are
a good Chef you're not gonna put
all sorts of things there at random yeah
right flavors have to be balanced things
have to go with each other that was a
big problem with modernist cuisine
wasn't it yes yeah and it didn't go
anywhere yeah right so so you have to
balance things out in a certain way that
makes sense of course we're talking in
that case we're talking about aesthetic
sense or or sense of of taste in in this
case the criteria a little bit more
strict because we're talking about
philosophy so yeah
how would you go about do it well first
of all at the very least you want a
coherent system that is internally
coherent system if it's philosophy you
cannot have a system that is that has
internal contradictions so if there are
Notions within your whatever your system
is they're internally contradictory or
shaking in any in any way those are I
think you have to resolve them you have
to either choose in one of or or another
notion or maybe throw a move out
whatever it is so cool so so there won't
be any possibility of like the oh all
roads lead to Rome we're all doing the
same basic thing kind of eclecticism
that you see some people as well I don't
I don't think so because that becomes an
exercise in rationalization that becomes
you know whatever I like I'm gonna pick
and if I don't like something I'm gonna
throw it out with no Rhyme or Reason I
think that there has to be the following
I think at least three things here one
is the coherence the internal coherence
another one is whatever's philosophical
system you come up with better be in a
in not in contradiction at least with
the empirical evidence coming from
science okay right now of course the
problem there is that the empirical
evidence coming from science changes all
the time yeah
um and so you might have to adjust your
system accordingly that is as we were
discussing a few minutes ago that's what
I'm doing with my own version of
stoicism right okay modern science tells
me that the universe is not a living
organism fine then that that things is
out and if it one day which changes and
you know let's say uh new discoveries in
quantum mechanics uh uh lead to the
conclusion that you know what actually
it is a living organism with thinking oh
great then then provenance is back yeah
now some people might be disturbed by
these kind of you know flux but I think
that if you that's the rational way to
go otherwise you have a religion
I was just thinking about how In Our
Lifetime going back to the culinary
stuff yes are eggs good for you or bad
for you I've been thinking about that
flip-flopping that right exactly it's
biology and nutrition as yeah coffee you
know should you drink a glass of wine
per day I mean if we could have stuff
that's trivial as that in the big
picture then surely you know if we find
out more about the universe as a whole
we should be able to adjust to that
now the interesting the the good thing
is and if you don't do that as I said
then you then you're sliding into a
religion I think religions also in a
sense are philosophies of Life uh but
they tend to be more rigid because
they're based not on arguments they're
based on allegedly scriptural Revolution
or you do end up with quite a few that
wind up being that uh I forget how you
just called it a minute ago but where
you can rationalize anything I mean you
look at contemporary Evangelical stuff
surrounding like you know politics and
you're like holy crap I mean
evangelicals 30 years ago would not have
bought into this this you know craziness
that's going on but now it's like
anything goes you know yeah
the third thing that I would do in fact
that I am doing in order to build a
neglective philosophy is just for
pragmatic purposes it makes sense to
start with a core
that you say okay I'm gonna take most of
this on board in my case stoicism I'm
going to take most of these on board and
then I'm gonna work on so instead of
study from scratch from zero it's like
oh I'm gonna come up with my own
philosophy of life from zero nothing
completely
um I'm gonna start with something that
has with the the test of time that lots
of people have worked on that lots of
people you know I want to build on what
other people have been doing it rather
than come up with my own you know I have
to reinvent the wheel essentially now I
think a good question here would be yes
but
could one start with different kind of
cores
and still come up with a coherent
philosophy of science of philosophy of
mine of uh sorry of life that is also
respect of respecting of Science and
it's useful Etc and I think the answer
is yes I I don't think there is only but
I I actually never claimed even when I
got into stoicism early on I never
claimed the stories unlike the ancient
stocks who would have claimed right that
was the app the answer and the bigger
and said now that is ours is the answer
and so on so forth I don't think so I
think one can live a life where if you
if you translate euda Moines as broadly
as possible as a life worth living for a
human being yeah I do think there is
more than one path
but that's not the same as saying all
roads lead to Rome first of all because
no a lot of rooms down a little roads do
not leave to realm
um they need you somewhere where you
don't want to be for one thing
um and some roads are better than others
you know some roads are work better they
are more conducive to what you want to
do but if somebody were to say to me so
you think that one can be a good human
being a good person by being a Buddhist
or a Taoist or a Epicurean or a stoic I
would say yeah probably
I you know my preference is for stoicism
but that part of that preference is is
cultural right I mean I did look into
Buddhism for instance and just didn't
speak to me but didn't speak to me
because I didn't grow up in that kind of
milieu I didn't you know a lot of the
terminology and all of the the way the
texts are written is like it's alien to
me literally alien to me and therefore
I'm much more comfortable with the
Hellenistic philosophies right and then
within those for some reason stoicism
spoke to me much more than epicureanism
or at least italianism but I can easily
see somebody going in a different
direction and still living a very good
human life
yeah so this leads to another
interesting question that Rob asked it's
one that I'm I'm going to want to hear
your reaction to it first and then I'll
tell you what mine is okay so he said
how do we distinguish one philosophy of
life from another to put it in perhaps
more technical terms what are the
principles of individuation for a
philosophy of life if any I would assume
logical consistency might be a play here
but perhaps not anything stronger that
we could make use of and so what I take
him to be asking about is how do we
fairly rigorously differentiate the
Essences or cores of philosophies of
life so we could devote stoicism or
aristotelianism or you know with
platonism it gets a little bit trickier
because we have Plato and then we have
the middle platonists so then we have
you know various neoplatonists that it
spills off into Christian neoplatonists
and Jewish neoplateness and and uh
um Pagan or neopig that is an excellent
question and I am curious about your
unanswered so I I thought about it for
for quite a bit
and my response would be well first of
all you might not be able to
differentiate every individual
philosophy sharply from every other
right some of them may belong to a a
sort of family resemblance I think that
for instance Cicero is right that all
the udemonic philosophies resemble each
other I do think that there are
differences between Plato news Marie
Satanism and stoicism and there are
enough differences that to me they are
distinct philosophies but they're
certainly far more close to each other
than let's say epicureanism or syrianism
or and of course Buddha is more you know
or taoism or something like that so I do
think there are clusters at least of
philosophism now how do we
differentiate or identify a philosophy
of life my take is that a philosophy
life typically has three components and
you'll see that these three components
also include religions
they they would make it so that
religions are in fact philosophies of
life one component is a metaphysics that
is there has to be some kind of General
story about how the world works
so if you're a Christian for instance or
Catholic uh well the world was created
by a Creator God with certain attributes
for certain reasons Etc if you're a
stoic uh the world is the result of
cause and effect it has the logos and
all that sort of stuff right
so there has to be a medicine
metaphysics typically that metaphysics
is
Loosely not one-on-one not not titling
not rigidly but more or less Loosely but
meaningfully connected in ethics where
the ethics is how we are supposed to
live your life right so
if you are a Catholic a Christian uh you
follow the ten commandments back at
Jesus better be important you know
exactly the you you follow the teachings
of Jesus that sort of stuff right if
you're a stoic you might adopt the four
candle virtues the dichotomy of control
that sort of you you will adopt the
notion that virtue is the most important
thing in life that sort of stuff right
so and then third
uh practices
that is some way to actually uh become a
better Christian or a better stoic etc
etc now in the case of the Christians
again you go to church you pray you read
and reflect on scripture you talk to
other Christians in the case of the
stoic you read the stories you reflect
on them you talk to other people you
practice a number of exercises and types
of meditations
etc etc so I think that these three
things yeah are identify pretty much any
philosophy of of life and you can see
easily that religions therefore become
part of it but if you start adding the
the other two criteria that I already uh
suggested that is internal coherence and
compatibility with science now most of
the regions are out
now now you start losing a bunch of
stuff right because because the science
really Cuts deeply uh into these things
and so it turns out that actually only a
subset remains viable but there's still
philosophies of Life they just don't
work very well in my mind
yeah so my own take is that it strikes
me and I'm sure Rob doesn't mean it this
way but it reminds me of all these
people who have their neat categories of
well this is what a conscient is like
and this is what a Cartesian is like and
cartesians by the way are at the bottom
of all the you know Mix-Ups and
modernity and this is what an
Aristotelian is like and very often
you'll be like well that's I've read
Aristotle and that's not aristotelianism
and I've read you know later
aristotelians like Alexander
vaphrodisius and that's clearly not the
Aristotelian tradition as you're
representing it and so there's a sort of
schematism that I think is is
um bad not just for philosophy it's not
like hurting philosophy as such but it's
bad for the people who want to
understand
philosophy they're they're setting up
obstacles in their their path and I I
like the family resemblance idea I often
use the term constellation you know like
there's like you know like with stoicism
there's no one single thing that is
stoicism it's a it's a whole bunch of
connected Concepts and they get a hell
of a lot stronger when they're mutually
reinforcing each other which is the way
I take Seneca to be to be representing
uh how stoicism works and I think it
works that way similarly with other
philosophies of life so that there's
going to be overlap and messiness
there's going to be within a tradition
people who are disagreeing within the
tradition I mean this is one of the
things I do take from Aleister McIntyre
who definitely takes the Aristotelian
Paradigm as like the right one and you
know Anthony long took him to task for
not seeing that stoicism was doing the
same sort of thing so like 20 years ago
yeah I know right yeah yeah and and I
think that you know McIntyre stresses
that if you have a healthy tradition
there's going to be some disagreements
within that tradition and also like
looking outward rather than like turning
Inward and being like we are of this
Essence and looking outward and saying
oh you know those platonists they got
something that we don't have let's see
if we can figure out how to incorporate
this or you know take later philosophies
oh the existentialists have come on the
scene and they're talking about freedom
and choice and stuff like that do they
have anything over there that that the
stoics could actually incorporate you
know maybe there'll be some places where
you can't take this stuff over here and
still be a stoic but there's probably
going to be a lot of things so I'm I'm
pretty resistant to the idea of
saying that we can rigorously or rigidly
distinguish one philosophy of life from
another I would agree I mean that said I
do think that
some philosophy at least some
philosophies of life and some religions
do have so again I understand them I
treat them as family resemblance
Concepts but I do think that some Trends
within that family resemblance are
much more crucial than others right that
if you drop those you really are going
to have a hard time for instance uh if
you say I'm I'm a Christian but I don't
believe that Jesus was the son of God
it's like
[Applause]
wait a minute yeah it's like that's
that's pretty crucial that's that's
where it gets really interesting because
for years and years and years when I
first started out teaching and I was
teaching in in Indiana State Prison and
I would teach religious studies as well
as philosophy classes I had to keep you
know my own religious uh affiliation a
secret from the guys because otherwise
some of them would be like hostile to me
and some would be trying to take
advantage of perceived ties and so I
would just like see what they had to say
and I was they would ask me about all
this really bizarre crap like you know
uh from the you know Book of Revelations
or Ezekiel all this this stuff and I'd
be like how are you doing with the
Sermon on the Mount because that seems
really really Central to me I mean if
you're not like actually enacting that
stuff who gives a crap about all this
other extrinsic stuff you know and and I
think today at least in America and I I
don't know how it is worldwide trying
frankly
but here in America we have a lot of
people who identify as Christians who
are diametrically opposed to what
Christianity at its best historically
stood for I would agree I agree but then
again the same happens within stoicism
right so to a much smaller scale because
stoicism is not as as important in terms
of numbers but uh you know that's why
recently on my sub stack I wrote an
article about the bad varieties of
stoices you know right right all these
stoicism with a dollar sign you know I
use stoicism so that become rich or I
use toys and so I pick up the girl you
know that sort of stuff it's like no I'm
sorry that you may be using stoic
inspired techniques yeah allow you to do
certain things but if you drop the
fundamental stoic notion that virtue is
either the only thing or by far the most
important thing in in somebody's life
and in fact not comfortable to anything
else then you're not a stoic and
if you lose the let's say the fullness
of the the virtues right because you do
see a lot of these broex who are all
about you know courage and they're
translated as you know manliness and
stuff like that but no justice
the fact that that Cicero and the stoics
are like well if you don't have uh
wisdom and Justice driving courage it's
no longer courage it's actually advice
um so so there are ways in which you
know if you drop certain fundamental
ideas you're really not going to be or
even Within
a subset of stoices right I mean you
could make an argument for instance at a
pictitious version of stoicism is in
fact significantly different from
earlier versions particularly because
it's so it hinges so so much on the
dichotomy of control well and the
dichotomy of control those those terms
are Aristotelian terms the emperor right
there in the nick of McCain ethics you
know that's right that's right it's
funny because you know people the only
reference in Epictetus in the stuff that
we have is aristotelians are basically
like epicureans but not as bad but you
know the proy racists right from the uh
from the Aristotelian tradition I mean
where that where hell where else is he
getting it from it's not from the stoics
you know no absolutely mean thing yeah
it's really quite startling right so you
cannot say oh I'm practicing stories
if you say yeah but I don't care about
you know
it's like okay well then what are you
doing or an Epicurean I mean again
epicures can reasonably disagree among
themselves on a number of things but if
they drop the notion that lack of pain
is the most important thing that defines
a a life worth living then then in what
sense are you an Epicurean right yeah
this isn't so the total side note here
and we do have to wrap up unfortunately
I wish we could talk a lot more but I I
have to go team we'll do it again yeah
so uh fake quotes right lots and lots of
people with Marcus Aurelius Aristotle
play to pick whoever you want that are
throwing these fake quotes out there and
then you know people like me and I think
you sometimes will call people out and
say no no that's that's actually not by
Aristotle and one of the reactions that
I get from a lot of people I mean some
people are gracious and they're like oh
oh man so so sorry you know I actually
care about truth so I'm not gonna I'm
gonna have to take this down
but quite a few of them are like well
you can't prove that he didn't say it
and uh uh I think it's true anyway even
though yeah I feel it's true exactly and
you're like well why the hell did you
attribute it to Marcus Aurelius then if
you weren't trying to hit your prestige
wagon to his proverbial star you know
take the take take it out take the
picture out just put the quote there and
don't say who it's by claim that it's by
yourself even though it's probably by
some you know early 20th century
self-help book or something this is
where a lot of these fake quotes or say
that it's uh from chat GPT you know
that's that's okay there you go yeah
yeah and so it's interesting to see it
is interesting psychology of well it's
still true and I'm still gonna post it
even though I've been called out and
revealed as as uh you know if I if I
quote somebody I make a point of putting
the actual reference me too yeah all
right
um because I mean it's it's only if it's
not just because we're Scholars of
course in Scholars if you if you're
writing a scholarly paper you better do
that otherwise but I think it's it's a
good idea in general for one thing
because people then can check whether
the fact that the person did say that or
or not and what was the com more
importantly what was the context yeah
there's an entire later letter by Seneca
where he says don't just go around
quoting people this beating quotation 33
it's a bad idea yeah um now we do it all
the time in part because social media
and the internet lend themselves to this
kind of thing but I think that the the
thing that we should ask ourselves is
what is the point of
putting out these quotes right yeah yeah
and I I think the point is to make
people think
about it you know whatever the
particular topic of the quote is but
more important to make him curious about
what the context of that quote was and
that's why you need to
say where the thing is from because that
way people and say oh really Seneca said
that in letter 25 okay let me go check
and read the whole letter and see what
the context was and you know maybe he
had a lot of other interesting things to
say so if you use it as a
beginning of a conversation it's I think
there it's a good idea but then you need
to give people the tools to continue the
conversation one of which is is a
reference right and one of my favorite
quotes on the Internet is um
um this this one that I paraphrase
because I don't I don't have it in front
of me it says uh don't believe every
philosophical quote you see on the
internet Plato
oh I've seen that attributed to Abraham
Lincoln oh yeah right there you go both
of them yes that's right so now we can
argue was it really played or was it
Opera Lincoln yeah yeah
it's uh it's a it's a really strange
phenomenon but you know we we do live in
strange times so that doesn't that
shouldn't surprise us probably yeah well
I think this is a good place to wrap up
we've been talking for quite a long time
and we have a lot more we can do this
again sometime I've absolutely very much
enjoyed this and I hope this will be
useful for my my viewers I'm pretty sure
it will be maybe caution some of them
away from the wrong sorts of eclecticism
you know or you know an orthodox
dogmatism right so thanks very much
Massimo for for coming here and letting
me kick start the the new set of ideas
that matter conversations it was a
pleasure thanks for having me